[Music]
up rain rain rain
hello and welcome to moses and friends
i'm your host and jacob woe look alike
moses storm uh we are live in the chat
if you guys want to uh comment along
i've been getting jacob wall a lot i
don't i don't personally
see it i do see that it would be maybe
in his gang
of like the guy that's like yeah boss
get him uh but we have a great show
today so i'm gonna make it tight keep it
loose because i had to fake an fbi raid
in like 10 minutes
uh the first guest i want to bring on is
a friend of mine that we haven't done
this before but
she's got a new book out that i want to
talk to her about uh please welcome
mandy johnson
manday and she's odd just like that
thank you for being here
thanks for having me for people who
don't know you you're you're a
successful comedy producer in in los
angeles you host uh
really one of the best indie shows that
there is or just
show period and you've recently put out
a book
called super serious and oral history of
los angeles independent
stand-up comedy here's the book right
here and
you sort of capture this time in
la stand up in the indie scene from from
your show
mixed with uh with portraits i get that
right
yeah sounds like a thing you did great
you did great
yeah very upset i didn't book the cover
you know uh the publishers the
publishers picked the cover
truly yeah sent me a handful and uh
that one just felt fitting it was very
silly was it something that you
that you always wanted to do is to put
out a book or
was it just like well i have all this
stuff and i mean this has to go
somewhere
i mean i think every photographer on
some level always wants to put out a
book you know eventually
uh the portrait series definitely didn't
start out to be a book
it didn't start out to be as big as it
was as it is now
but as it kind of grew bigger and bigger
around like
year six of the show um people started
asking me if i was gonna do a book
and then it kind of took another couple
years to find a book agent and
sell it and do all the things i
definitely did not know it was going to
be a book had i known her
been a book i probably would have chose
a different face
because you would tell people to do one
of two things before the show would
start
hey take a silly one and then we'll do a
serious one to go along with the show
that you're
curious so there's there's some great
photos in here there's some beloved
people
in here uh our own conan o'brien makes
an appearance in the book
he does it's very fun nicole buyer
great friend people have some very funny
whimsical shots here look at this even
anthony jeselnik
has shown off his slap stick
then we get to the sad white man page
that i find myself on my depression
era photo you know you're being very
serious you're taking the serious prompt
seriously moses and i appreciate that
took it very serious my whole family
just died of cholera
and famine even even matt broner
no known goof yeah you guys end up in
serious you're doing it correct
yeah i think you nailed it i i feel
great even known camajin
neil brennan looks a little bit happier
than me
yeah he like turned those slightly you
guys did a nice proper
like head-on you know and yeah i like it
took the note too well uh it's really
cool because what i really liked about
the book
i mean part of it is like you're
nostalgic just to see your friends in
comedy because we're all locked down
right now
but there's there's great interviews in
here a lot of comedians that
people would know are in this book and
it's really cool for us
to have because it's so it's the closest
thing that we have to a yearbook
yeah it's really it's very fun i mean i
didn't
think if we were going to be in a
pandemic when we scheduled the time the
book was going to come out
uh we were trying to time it close to
just the ten year of the show which
didn't happen because of the pandemic
but
yeah it's been nice i think to have it
during this time
where we all can't be together and we
can have a little bit of
pre-pandemic comedy like memorializing
history forever
so yeah a little sad way to put it but
but yeah i get it it was really nice to
to read through it and to see
friends in in the book and just kind of
remind
of us this time that we really love and
that hey it's still out there
eventually so it did make it a little
easier that one day in quarantine
like oh yeah these are all the people in
here
was there any interview in the book that
that surprised you of like someone that
maybe do the show
um they didn't think was gonna do the
show or talk to you for the book
no i think pretty much everyone did chat
with me i really loved carrying
kel gareth's interview um i thought her
interview was really great because she
i think her time kind of in and out of
the scene when she took a break when she
was
for work stuff you know she has a
different perspective on the value of it
um i also think that kind of having the
range of
veteran comedians like andy kindler and
karen have been around since like the
80s to
younger comics like you were interviewed
for the book you know who've been around
l.a for less time than that kind of it's
a nice to show like the expansiveness
of the scene and how it kind of like
ebbs and flows to fit
however many comedians need it to fit
and it kind of morphs around what comedy
needs
so it was an interesting thing to learn
about as i interviewed people
it's really cool and i would highly
recommend the book not just because i'm
in it
in that it does exactly what you said
and then it mixes those those two things
where it's
seasoned comics with very new people
it's the same thing you did with your
live shows where i could go up with
people that i
grew up watching and and you know have
to follow them
and it's the same thing with the book of
people that are you know just new to
comedy
like we're in a book now
you're a comedian yes the best
representation of independent comedy
is that and as big cities where those
comedians live
everybody starts to work on material and
the best place to do it a lot of times
is independent shows because there's
just more of them than the clubs
and those audiences are more patient
because they pay less money
and more into seeing the process a lot
of times so that's great
i think you captured a really great
thing in the book
yeah yeah super serious an oral history
of los angeles independent comedy mandy
thank you so much for
for being here and for making us a
yearbook officially
thanks for having me mrs good to see you
thanks mandy bye
bye that's mandy johnson grab the book
my next guest you know him from space
force on netflix
mandalorian uh bojack horseman please
welcome my very funny friend asif
ali asif thank you for being here oh
oh man you know what moses
this is exactly this is exactly what i
was
what i was hoping for to meet you in
this setting i finally get to see
the inside of of where you live and and
you didn't disappoint man
you didn't disappoint you have the the
saudi orb that trump and and those guys
put their hands on
i'm i'm really pumped about it i'm also
in the book i'm also in the book
you're in the book let's see did you do
something fun for the book you look sad
no he looks so fun
just a sad guy with something so you
just did exactly your dmv
photo for that you know yeah but you
know how you were on on the white page i
was
we got the i got the brown section here
you got the brown
section yeah give hassan the full page
give him the full page i mean he
deserves it you know he is an
icon and i love that they gave him they
picked the worst
for someone that is constantly lauded on
his perfect
tear it was it was a comparison
this book is a takedown to hassan full
take down
about his hair and he the one time he
didn't get
a fade up we got the sides going wild
rose
um how are you doing because it feels
like you've stayed
busy because you do a lot of voiceover
work you have an incredible voice
i've been getting into the voice game
i've been getting into the voice game
i'm doing this show called devil may
care
uh for sci-fi that will be out whenever
they're done editing that
i did like a thing on uh the star trek
uh
lord dex and what if i just continued
doing that for 45 minutes
yeah it's really good the amount of
things you're on you start listing
commercials you're on
ah did you sink lower and lower in the
air
in high school i ran the eight-minute
mile
yeah absolutely definitely keep going
but um yeah i've been doing voiceover
that's been fun you're doing voiceover
work
it seems like you got a really great job
before the shutdown
you're on the mandalorian i yeah i did
the mandalorians that was a great gig
um they they
it was so expensive and you know
you and i will we'll usually do we'll do
like an indie thing
right or like most normal television
show right like even like sunny side
it's just a tv show
and an indie show yeah you get it's a tv
show
kelpin had a couple gopros and then you
go on a show and you're like
oh if this is the whole company
this isn't just like a oh if this
doesn't do well
or whatever we'll be fine there's always
pilot season and then there's shows
where it's like this is the fourth
quarter
we have merchandise we have a whole
you know 100 million dollar ad campaign
we have a whole thing and if
if people are not wearing big dog size
t-shirts
and these are not flying off the shelves
our whole company
will go under and so when you're working
on a thing like that
i remember i got there and walking from
the doors to where our rooms are
we had to wear a full cloak with a hood
because where we were shooting there was
a particular
part of like a highway overpass thing
and the lady was saying that
people were camping out like they were
getting dropped off
like paparazzi were driving being like
i'll jump out grand theft auto style
just to maybe get a long
distance photo of someone's random
outfit
and then some person who's so into star
wars can sort of put together like
oh that guy's hat and his shoes means
that
he might be from this planet which might
mean that the story
could be about going from here which
might be
that it blows the whole thing because
they're they're insane about it so
everyone wants a piece if you do
anything that's star wars related
people want to know things get these
those whole websites that are just about
getting the exclusive so you had to wear
a whole cape
yeah off chance that someone would be on
a highway
and then pick a a blurry photo of you
and then piece together
that you were one on this yeah and
a crucial part of the story and the
crazy part is like okay
i can tell the guy getting dropped off
and just being on a highway overpass
taking photos but then like how does he
coordinate the pickup
yeah and if you've ever dropped anything
on the highway
um it's it's a you got to take another
80 minute lap yeah yeah it's a very it's
a very tough thing
um i'm doing i'm like in the middle of
doing a
uh a marvel show so we shot
80 percent of that and it really is just
all credits this whole interview is just
all credits
and i'm gonna bring jay larson on he's
like i don't know i'm like a dad
uh i have like a life and so i only
bring this up to say that when people
take it
that seriously like i was talking to a
dude on there and they're like
it's like a double edge sort of like you
don't want that kind of craziness while
you're making the show because
people are like trying to sneak into
everyone's instagram to try to like
put clues together like they're
detectives and wait this is for the
marvel show
yeah yeah yeah are you the before
picture of camel nagiani
did you book it i went out for it it was
a very offensive project
this is the the pre-protein shake
version yeah
minute montage
where listen would you do some reshoots
with the beginning of this
okay you're not strong enough and i'm
like i'll show you
this should be your credit just the
before picture of kumail and gianni that
people know exactly what you're
going in for can i tell you something
before i finish that
i cannot stress you how many times and
this is even with glasses awesome and
this might be subconsciously why i wear
the glasses too
how many times people will come up to me
i guess
in l.a it's like an la thing and be like
oh
you did a great job in the thing that i
definitely wasn't
in yes i brought this up not because
me me flaming racist but i was at a show
with you at westwood and they're like
from silicon valley
and they brought you up thinking you
were this was like your once looking bad
okay so
please go i was just trying to un-cancel
myself first later i would later i was
on silicon valley but
that that this was year one this is yeah
yeah yeah yeah and this is what i've
become now
i just agree i
so you don't pull the rip cord you don't
say oh no it's actually not made because
it's like
yeah if you don't if you're not going to
do the work and you're going to have
what i call white people blindness they
just like uh brown glasses done
done all you have to do is be like hey
did you work on that thing
that's truly all that you had to say
give yourself an
out don't be so sure even even when i
introduced your credit to the beginning
i was like bojack of course
everything's said with a rising
i just feel like there is a an agreement
though yeah amongst
all people who get confused for the
other person
where we just we are on our best
behavior we just say yes
we're on our best behavior and then we
just does this give you kind of license
to be a huge
dick like you could you could if
someone's like oh okay
yeah this is obviously cal pen then
you're just like yeah man working for
the obama administration was [ __ ]
the guy's a fake man he was totally
going to pizza restaurants all the time
and then people like he's lost it this
gives you this freedom are you ever
tempted you know what if i was really
evil that would be the move to take each
and every other indian
actor in la down they'd be like are you
you worked in uh
you were in love birds right and i go
yeah but also
i love white supremacy when are we
bringing that back
make sure to tell your friends that i
definitely
said that i met this guy moses storm on
the set of lovebirds great way to plug
myself
as being in that movie and he opened my
mind up
about white people and that you know
they're burning and they shouldn't be
alive they shouldn't be outside
and i i really think they have a point
anyway i'm going to this rally and
honestly you may not want to work with
me in the future but
there's probably a guy out there with
glasses that you should probably
definitely book
it's so cool to see you getting these
huge jobs because
i mean you and i have come up exactly at
the same time i feel like where
we've been on sets that are just exactly
like you're saying these indie things
where it's like a friend's
favor the budget is like a tangerine
and some goldfish we did a web series
for subway together
oh my god that's a real thing
that no one can find the record out
because they have pulled it
because jared from subway made a little
appearance and this is before
uh people understood branded content so
with a certain
large streaming network that i won't
name uh
where it was dipping their toes and it
was a subway
sponsored very heavy-handed
product placement show sitcom
that we all worked at a subway and
you were brought in i didn't know jared
made an appearance yeah well i was in it
with him
this is the thing i've been trying to
track down so please if anyone out there
can find this i can't tell you the
amount of money i would pay if there's
got to be
some record of it because there's
there's nothing you kept it
you kept it on your reel not the jared
part but yeah there is
there is like a he comes in there's like
a funny interaction yeah i even talked
to him about his life i was like so
what's your life like like what do you
do he goes
it's pretty chill let's do these
corporate events and then nothing else
but there's actual video of me doing a
behind-the-scenes thing
and i'm like you know 21 trying to get
like just lucky to be there
and i say about jared's like it's so
cool to see jared
because every subway you go and you see
the cardboard cutout of him you know and
now he's on the set
he's essentially like the brad pitt of
subway
there's that pull quote from me oh my
god can you imagine people don't realize
how many
things like that you have to do to get
one
thing that you're okay with talking
about in public have you done
commercials in the lockdown because it's
a little bit different process
now can i tell you something really so
whenever so they're doing commercials in
home yes you're 100 right
have i done any of them no and part of
the reason is because they're always
like
you know yes they want to shoot
commercials and they want to shoot in
your house but if your
house doesn't look like a
set they don't want to be involved with
you so i have a lot of people who are
like
oh yeah we worked with austin before
he's great let's definitely bring him on
this is a commercial with dj khaled
whoever right
yeah and your house has to match dj
khaled's house
an impossible task an impossible task
you don't have a jet ski i have a jet
ski i don't have
marble and they're like yeah so dj
khaled comes up and he goes hey cool
and you're supposed to be brushing your
teeth and i'm like
it is he in my house or is he is it
supposed to be like
is it supposed to look like his house
and they're like i don't know sort of
like in between
and then you do the audition and they're
like great that's super fun now can you
give us a tour
of your house and then you take your
camera
and you're like okay and you're like
showing them your house
and then you can kind of sense the
deflated
like your house is bombing essentially
it's like you booked it but the house
didn't book it your sad apartment
they're like oh the wealth inequality
gap is too
large between you and dj khaled
i'm like i'm like i like my place but i
can just feel it i'm just like
ah well i guess we're just gonna have to
find somebody else because this guy is
living in a tent it seems this will not
work
seems to be living under a freeway
trying to capture photos of star wars
your apartment does look like edward
norton's place before he blows it up in
fight club
the same rug where it's like i just sort
of i'm a corporate machine i have a
zigzag rug
everything from the ikea catalog i eat
noodles there every night and i
just want to change my life i just want
to punch myself in the face
it is a great out for us though if you
don't book something it's like they
don't like the place
you know dude i'm going to keep using it
even when we can
audition in person again they could
sense the zigzag carpet
they had it out for me they knew i had
laid on that carpet
panicking about this audition this was
so great talking to you i just missed
talking to you and seeing you around
likewise dude maybe i'll just show up
outside your window one of these days
please do and i'm like what hussain
minaj
uh it is great to see you so it's
mandalorian
people obviously know about that marvel
project is coming out
a bunch of voice-over work uh yeah devil
may care we'll be on nbc sci-fi
sometime uh in the new year
very excited about it and then subway is
doing some fantastic
branded content that you have to check
out please find this for us
because we need to do a whole show about
the behind the scenes of this awesome
valley everyone
good to see anybody bye bye
he's in the book my next guest
is also in this book this is gonna be
the thread through the whole thing okay
i thought you were reading this book
please welcome jay larson
jay how are you i'm great i didn't know
if ossif was done dropping any more
credits
you know what i mean he's gonna pop up
as a picture-in-picture
like when they play like you know the
less important game that's a blowout and
he's gonna be just dropping credits in
there
because he's booking things as we speak
he just booked right now
are you working are you staying busy oh
yeah look at this i i saw you
ask ossif if he's done any commercials i
directed a commercial
during this whole thing yeah and then
just for future reference if you could
take all of your questions based off of
awesome's credits it's going to help us
do a
great thread for the show that's you
know what i mean i like
unity and concise yeah okay so you
directed a commercial
pandemic-wise which is it's already
difficult enough to do a commercial
because it's a hodgepodge crew
people that have not worked together
yeah are you doing this remotely are you
on set
no we did on set we did two days one day
on set in a church
and then another day out at a golf
course are you getting rapid tested
before are they just winging it
test the day before we had someone on
set you got your temp
checked three times throughout the day
everyone's in math
social distance mass off for shooting
but you're in a mask the whole time
yeah how does that work because you like
to when you direct you like to scream an
actor's faces
i get in people's faces big time bro you
should
have a breakfast so you're you're on
your game don't eat my raisins
get away from crap sir kevin nealon was
our lead
and so like i have such respect for
kevin nealon like trying to give
direction i'd be like
hey kevin what if we and he's like oh
yeah you're gonna love this you're gonna
love what i do here and then you
everyone would just be laughing you're
like
hey yeah let's let's move on i don't
gotta do anything yeah it was great
are you gonna do more of those or was it
such a weird experience or you're just
like
let's just wait or you're like let's
work i had no problem with it i'm on a
i write on a show and i wrote and
directed
five sketches for the show during the
pandemic as well
i think if everyone is just cautious and
you're smart and you're safe
i mean you're seeing commercials with
people in mass so clearly they're making
content or
shooting commercials during cobit you
know what i mean
unless jeep grand cherokee knew about
this
and they released the virus i'm saying
dude
are they behind it is this something lee
iacocca
you know was ahead of the game on i know
that might be an old school reference
for you
and maybe some of the audience but i'm
educated
and i'm informed you know what i mean
yeah you're informed it is it does
change the relationship
uh on set a little bit it's a little
less collaborative and that everyone's
afraid of each other
and also the writing room can be weird
i've been in some writing rooms now
where you don't know if your joke that
you pitch bombed or it's
zoom bombed and it just crashed yeah or
there was just a delay
what if it it crushed but the delay was
so long you missed the entire response
yeah and then you already back out like
if someone pitches a joke it's like oh
yeah so then he fills up the back of the
truck with a bunch of toasters and then
that falls
but yeah i don't think we have the
budget for that so we'll just yeah we'll
move on
yeah well we can we can rip on it guys
maybe maybe later
yeah i'm in a writer's room i have been
the entire pandemic
and it's like crazy we have some people
in florida and some people in la
so we were you know like working out
times
and just making it work you just get so
comfortable on zoom just being like well
let's just make it work
you think uh moving forward industry
wise writers room and
even some sets will be a little bit more
remote because we've
proved it can be done i hope not i hope
that
listen i'm all about being safe and
we've been like completely safe with our
kids and like groceries i haven't eaten
out anywhere
but i also believe that like when we get
control like dj khaled yeah
you know what i mean once we get control
of this that we should i would writers
run like
you need to be next to people with
people riffing
like getting a sense of them seeing them
like that's like there's such a
it's such a part of the creative process
that i think like
i hope maybe there will be some rooms
that will i think we should use it as
like an advantage to be able to be
remote if someone needs to be but
otherwise
i think being in a room together like
really benefits
the writing yeah absolutely because it
is an energy thing where you need to
throw out a bunch of bad ideas to get to
the good one
and you can only really feel safe doing
that when everyone's doing it you're all
in the same room and you can pick up on
certain social cues
like you'll read comments with this like
at the live comments like this is a
podcast boring it's like was just
different than being on stage
yeah having to deal with this delay i
also think when you're in a
zoom room you're constantly like the
clock is constantly ticking like when is
this ending
whereas when you're in the writer's room
so you might just like accept joke
because you're like well this thing is
going to end some point let's just get
that jump done whereas in a writer's
room
you could like be like let's just wait
on that let's go work on this and like
oh dude you know
how are you handling it with kids are
you homeschooling
you're supervising homeschooling i'm not
a big uh
i don't want my six and a half year old
on three hours of zoom call so we
de-enrolled them from school and set up
our home as a home school
and then we hired a teacher that we like
went through the covet process with so
now she like
every day nine to two is with my kids
and like they do project-based learning
activities
learning they do field trips you know
it's a lot more organic and
a higher engagement level than zoom
so you hire so you're essentially a
principal yeah i'm i'm vp my wife got
the principal title i mean it's not a
big deal it's not a huge deal
um you seem really upset about it it
hasn't it hasn't been a thing dude
it hasn't come up it hasn't been an
issue i'm not saying i have better
credit wait whatever you know what i
mean
whatever you have the same power as your
your wife is the principal don't you
know the structure of the
principal vice principal i'm the fun guy
vice principal kind of seems like uh
lunch is over you know you can survey
the lunchroom and then you're back in
yeah that sounds right that's kind of
that's pretty accurate
you move everyone's cars when the car
needs to back out
you gotta move cars you know hopefully
you get a promotion
so you it's also on you to kind of keep
the kids
busy i saw your building stuff you built
a whole uh
essentially science experiment table
outside
i just love being interactive with my
kids and like so i we built a science
table i built them a lego table
i like doing adventures with them like
when the whole thing started
my job was like the first two weeks of
kobe they were like let's just be loose
and the kids were out of school so like
i would take them on hikes and then find
a picnic table and we'd like
collect leaves and turn them into
projects i just like that idea of like
constantly making learning a fun
experience
you know yeah it's a great time to be
picking up leaves and anything you find
in the street right now
any anything experience you know and
then we like what is that bacteria
what better way to learn about cobit
getting covered
i think your kids are going to find the
vaccine on one of your leaf trips which
is actually
them just cleaning the yard listen when
you say leaf trip
it almost sounds like devaluing it
no it sounds like i actually want to go
on it it sounds like you're a great dad
and talking to you makes me wish i had a
great dad
because this sounds this sounds fun it
is fun yeah it is very fun they're fun
they're wild kids so
they they they take to it what else
we've been doing to keep them busy
you've been showing them movies and
no not at all you know what i did is uh
i've been doing like we did this field
trip to the beach we went to the beach
with like my buddy and his kids but
we've been watching goonies are you a
goonies fan
uh i wasn't allowed to watch a lot of
movies growing up like i thought star
wars the most boring movie because my
parents had edited all the violent parts
out
so it's just a movie a bunch of people
talking and then a brown bathrobe falls
on the ground
yeah totally sucks but no i have i've
seen clips of it but i haven't seen
the entirety of the movie yeah well
goonies
goonies is you know it's spielberg dude
you're like dude this is steven
spielberg
and we showed it to the kids and they
fell in love with it and you know
there's a treasure hunt and there's a
map they follow
so after we watch it i took the kids to
el matador beach
which has got like rocks and caves and i
made the night before a treasure map
and made it look old and like you know
put old writing on it
and put like the rocks i drew the rocks
and put x marks the spots we got to the
beach
buried it in the sand by our mat and
then when my buddy got there i went and
took like a stick that was charred and
put
x's on the rocks where i had written
them on the map
and then at lunch i was just like have
my hand in the sand and i was like oh
what's this
and i hand it to my son and he was just
like
dude and like the kids lost their minds
and then we went on the treasure hunt we
found the x's i bought old coins
or brought them and then hid them and
the kids found them and then
it just turned into like their whole
world was like we gotta find more
treasure dad
we gotta find it we gotta dig and i was
like
i looked at my buddy i'm like should we
tell them like that this isn't real and
he's like no
dude let them go i'm like all right so
now they just like
they believe that one eyewilly from
goonies
lived so now they're just gonna believe
that every scenario is is possible
you're gonna be in your regular day life
they get on a bus and you're like this
is the bus from speed
don't let this bus stop they think this
is baby yoda
for real dude dad has the hookup with a
very homemade version of yoda what if
someone else found the coins on the
beach what if
what if you accidentally blew someone
else's mind
i had the coins on me and then when we
get to the x when they wouldn't look i
would just go
and i just drop it down like hey what's
that and then they'd be like
you know that's genius so burr
you know burrs a friend and burr is in
the mandalorian
and the kids made a video and we sent it
to burr like hey
you were so great in the mandalorian and
then he sent them a message back
and they were just like now like you'll
see my son like talking kids like on the
playground or in the pool and he'll be
like
have you seen the have you seen the
mandalorian and the kid be like yeah and
he's like
do you know episode four uh the guy the
bounty hunter and i'm like hey
just chill out dude you know what i mean
like he's already names
game droppings so your son is asa valley
and that's been a challenging experience
that's really cool that you have that
that that hookup in that you can
do so they think like dad's cool dad is
the guy
i think i'm pretty cool i feel like you
cook for your kids do you go all
out here like it's mac and cheese and no
we go water pasta
i do real plates real glasses forks
there's no separation anymore no plastic
plates
wine salad for little vino come on
you won't get drunk it just pairs well
it opens their palate man
you want them to try new stuff give them
a little whiskey listen up it's for
their palette
it's gonna be a more distinguished
palette i put rum
on my daughter's gums when she was
teething when she was really young
yeah i'll never forget it like just
holding her here
dipping in and just be like rubbing it
on her gums and she was just like oh
yeah this is pretty tight i'm like oh
nice
and then like she went to bed and like
we had been having a problem getting her
to go to bed
and i just crushed it with this captain
morgan is what i gave her
and then i hear her crying like a half
hour later
and she had thrown up everywhere in the
room
yikes lightweight dude yikes
so this concludes our child services
interview
uh we'll be following up with some forms
wait what do you mean we think you're
a great dad we want you to write a book
i love it
anything else that uh i skipped over
talk sports anything you want a plug
what do you got coming up what's
what's this podcast if you want to check
this out cause you tell really great
stories
it sounds like a dig i don't know i
stopped podcasting during this as well
but there's a bunch of episodes
somewhere yeah i had one called the
through line that's out there you can
check out the commercial
i just shot for callaway with kevin
nealon it's actually a short film it's
like an eight minute short film
which you can check out callaway's
posting if that's of interest to people
if you're into branded content that's
our whole audience and then throughline
is the is the podcast we just tell great
stories on that yeah
very nice just put some whiskey on your
finger put it in your mouth
listen to this podcast jay thank you so
much for
helping us out doing the show you got it
man thanks for having me
yeah this is fun all right later moses
later
all right that's gonna do it for us
thank you guys so much for watching the
show
a huge thank you to jay larson assaf ali
and all of his credits and mandy johnson
with
again her new book super serious
i think it's available now so check that
out and uh we'll be back in two weeks
i'm moses storm thank you guys so much
for joining us good night
[Music]
you